I feel like if I'm addicted to any drug
my drug of choice is being late I know I
know you can't smoke it I know you can't
snort it but being late is a drug it's
like an aamine it's like a stimulant
think about it if you would to be at
work at 9:00 and you wake up at 9:30 Woo
you're
up holy hell you look like a drug addict
your eyes are popped you're sweating
your dve work I'm super late I'm super
late I'm super late I'm super late yeah
you get to work it's like you're coked
up you're talking about I'm so sorry I
hate myself I'm gay I love
you oh man that's
bad mark is someone who is a master of
the metaphor he creates these incredible
associations where he's basically
relating one item to another item in
this particular scenario he's relating
being late to being like taking a drug
it's an incredible form of creating
humor because it allows you to find
humor in both of those topics if you
have to explain something to someone you
can use a metaphor to do so an easy way
to create what items you're going to
share in that metaphor is to create
what's called a 5x5 list where
essentially you create a list of five
things related to the topic or the thing
that you want to explain and a list of
five things related to the metaphor that
you are going to use creating metaphors
is something that an inventor does well
one of seven different humor personas if
you want to find out exactly what kind
of funny you are check out the quiz in
the bio